Hey guys, hope you're doing good. In the chapter I'm going to teach you my personal approach to CRD or Gandal range theory. Now I explain this concept over one and a half years ago on my YouTube, but it wasn't really in that much detail. I just told you guys that candles are ranges and basically you can take a turtle soup whenever the candle highs taken out or the candle low is taken out. Now a lot of people on Twitter,
Consider this as their own concept. It is not my concept. It is not their concept. This is all ICT
right there's nothing
There's nothing that someone invented right someone else invented. This is all ICT
So what exactly is CRD so serious candle range theory right every candle is a range and that is absolutely obvious right that
There's nothing new to it, but then there are some timings that if we
focus on, you know, you can trade with very high probability. So although every
single candle is a range, it doesn't mean that every single candle's range is
high probability. We have specific times that make those candle ranges high
probability. So the number one is 1M for our candle. So this is a 4 hour candle
And this is also a four hour candle. Okay, so we're gonna have two high probability turtle soups in a day
Now one can work and one cannot work or both
Total soups can work in a day so basically you will win two trades in a day
Now don't get confused. I'm gonna explain each and everything all right
So this may sound a bit complicated, but it is not just listen to me
So this is the first four hour candle and that's gonna open at 1am
And then this is the second four hour candle and that's gonna open at 5M
So practically we want to wait
For the candle closure so the 1M4 hour candle needs to close so once it closes
We are simply marking out the 1M4 hour candle high and low
Now there are two ways to trade this
Okay, the very first step is we need to see when the candle closes, right?
The 1M4 our candle.
We have to drop down to 5 minute time from and let's suppose that the high is taken out.
Now, I want to see a market structure shift also acceptance back into the range, the candle
range.
range high, this is a candle range low. Once the candle closes, we are waiting for a rate either
to the candle high or the candle low. So in this example, you can see that the next candle opened
here and on the five minute dump room, we took out the four hour candle high. And then we also have
a marker structure shift and we also have acceptance back into the range. I want to see price come
back into the range. Right? And that's going to increase the probability. Now, I am simply
just taking my entry from the Fair Valley Gap or a breaker block or an autoblock. And here is the risk
management for this strategy. You take your entry, put your short bit of the high, and you close
50% off your position at one to one risk to the water ratio. So once you reach one to one, you are
basically taking 50% off your position and then you're also going break even. Now you are leaving the trade
till the candle low is taken out. So this is going to maximize the profits. Now the second way
your trade is you have a period rate on the four hour time from this is a four hour candle
on the forward timer.
Let's suppose that you have a fair value gap.
Now, once price takes out the four hour candle high
and it also taps into a period, right?
And then gives you a marker structure shift
on the five minute diagram that makes it high probability.
Okay?
There are always some ways to increase the probabilities
of the strategy, all right?
And that's what I'm teaching my goal is to teach you ways
that you can approach the strategy.
And there are two ways.
One is of course gonna have low probability
is not a huge difference. If you're in account for PD arrays, your win was going to just go
5 to 10% higher. That's it. But it's not very significant when you're going to win these
massive trades. So you take 50% off at 1 to 1 and then you basically hold till this level.
Now of course I'm going to give you examples and your confusion will be gone.
So it's very simple. Just five minute mark is actually shift. Now here is one scenario that
second I can write.
So let's assume, just let me just remove this.
The new candle opens, you have price keeps going up, right?
And then you get a market structure shift.
Now I will not take my entry, why?
Because price didn't come back into the range.
So even though price can come, go here,
and I wanna see price close below the range.
So now once it does that, let me just remove this.
Once it does that, then I can look to take my entry
from any pediatric that is present, right?
So I can basically just consider this
as a autoblog and then take my entry.
I just wanna see price come back into the range.
So, very simple that.
Now, here's another thing that you need to know.
Okay, this is very important.
So if you do not get an entry before the five AM candle closes,
right? So let's suppose that the 1M4 are kind of closed but you know the rate the
price doesn't take out the 1M candle high or the low before the 5M kind of
closes. That's gonna be around 8 right? I'm gonna explain everything when I go
to the live charts but try to understand what I'm saying. If the rate doesn't
happen. So let's suppose price keeps on, you know,
console letting, console letting, normal, right? But then the new candle opens
the five, if candle opens and, you know, it basically, oh, my bad, my bad,
my bad, let me explain it because this is very confusing, right? So the five
in candle open is when you're going to see the rate, right? So this open is the
open of this candle. I hope that makes sense. The open of this candle is the open of this
candle. This is just for like, it's a picture to explain things, right? So if you don't
get a raid before the five him can encloses, then you have to wait for the raid of the
five him candle. I know it's confusing, right? Don't worry, I'm gonna go to the live
type charts and it's going to clear each and everything.
But if the rate doesn't happen of this candle,
then we have to wait for this candle to close.
Then we have to look for the rate of this candle.
This one becomes useless.
This candle becomes useless.
Now I'm just going to go to the live charts.
And I'm going to explain everything.
So all of your confusion is going to be over.
All right.
So here is example one.
This is the one AM candle and this is the five AM candle.
Now, look at this one AM candle.
All you need to do is mark out the high
and the low of that candle.
Very simple, all right?
Now, if I drop down to five minute time from,
you can see that this was the candle high
and it got swept right here.
Now we simply look for a shift in the market structure, right?
And around here, we have that.
Now I was going to send this setup today in the discord,
but I send the other one, which was this and it turned out to be a loser.
So very unfortunate, whoever took that trade.
This would have been an awesome winner.
You can see that we had this auto block here.
Right? This fair value gap as well.
This could have been basically your entry
somewhere around here.
And you would go shot right here.
Stop right above the high.
At one to one, you would take like 50% or 40% of your trade.
Go break even and then hold till here.
Now, what I sometimes like to do is use my fib from the last high that was formed to the last low that was formed before market structure shift and I used the standard deviation projections to take my profits.
Right? So, if the real draw on liquidity, which is the kind of low is near the negative 2 or negative 2.5 or negative 4, then it increases the probability of the setup.
So this happened today and it happens every single day.
Now I want to give you guys the pairs and assets that this works with.
So first off it works with gold that it works with your USD and that works with NAS100,
US30 and S&P 500.
Alright?
You don't have to trade anything else.
single day you choose one pair or asset and then you trade that asset or pair.
You don't have to take two different rates. So for example if you are short on
gold you do not want to buy your USD. You just have to trade one pair which
ever presents the setup. Don't trade multiple pairs at the same time. So let's
So, first I want to the next example now.
Alright guys, so here is example two.
So over here you can see that we have a PDA rate,
that is a four hour free body gap,
then we have the five AM four hour candle.
Alright?
So this is the opening price, the candle closes here.
So we simply mark out the high,
and the low of that candle.
So this is a method two,
where price goes into the PDA rate.
So you can see that the high of the five
candle was taken out and price also was in a PDA ray.
And this is the candle low.
So this would be a redraw on liquidity.
So if I go to the five minute time from now,
zoom out a bit, you can see that this was the high.
So this tiny bit, let me just mark this up like that.
So at nine, actually, the five AM candle closes.
at 9M, the 5M candle closes.
Remember that.
So we get a clean shift in the market structure.
We have this big auto block,
so a good entry point would be this
because that is a BPR.
And you can see that this would have been
a shot position just right here.
You can also take your, you know,
usually I would wait for the extreme level to be taken,
but since price is already giving me one to two,
right? There is no need to take your entry from here because price is giving us decent
restorer wall. Now, you can see that your entry would have been here at one to one. You would
take around 40 to 50% of your position, go break even, right? And then you can see that
the take profit was hit. Your entry, remember must be before 12. Always, okay, 12. So our
entry was at 11 something. So this was a beautiful trade we tapped into PDA Ray, you know,
and this is meant to do. Let's move on to the next example. All right, guys, so here is
another example. And you can see that we have the one M candle here. Price did take it out,
but it went up and you may have got stopped at break even with one partial. Now, however,
If we look at the 5M4 hour candle, right,
we simply mark out the low and the high of that candle.
Okay, so we get, we have the 1M and the 5M candle.
These are important. Now if I go to the 5 minute chart here,
you can see that after taking this, we had a shift in the market structure,
so you can account for weeks as well for this strategy.
And most importantly, we closed back above the range, above this low.
Then we have the autoblock, right?
A very clean trade.
And if we use our standard deviation tool,
although the draw on liquidity is here,
there's a higher draw on liquidity that might be here.
So this around here, because it is above the negative two.
So this could be your final take profit level.
Let me just close this real quick.
So a very beautiful entry from this auto block here
and it played out perfectly.
And this strategy works really well
for some reason with the US study.
If you want like insane consistency,
then I suggest you trade this,
because it has like a very, very high win rate for this like S.
Let me give you guys one more example
and then I will end this chapter.
All right guys, so here is the final example
and I'm looking at the one M candle,
so I'm gonna mark out the low.
And I'm gonna mark out the high.
Now, do note that we are inside this PRA.
This is a autoblock, right?
A bullish autoblock.
So that increases the probabilities.
Always remember that.
And one key thing to note,
we are in the discount.
So that is also a plus point.
These small things, if you try to implement them
in every strategy that I've taught you,
your win rate is gonna improve, all right?
So the one M candle low was taken off.
So let's study what happened.
So if I go here, right, the low was taken out first,
and notice what happened.
This has to be the cleanest example.
We swept this low, we broke the structure, market structure.
We also broke the structure.
Very nice.
Then we have this fair value gap.
Look at the precision here.
The bodies were beautifully respected.
So this could have been a long position.
Your stop would go right below this low and at one to one,
somewhere around here, right?
One to one.
This is the entry.
Probably goes up here.
So let me just do that.
You would go break even somewhere around here.
And then you can see that if you held till here,
this would have given you a beautiful wrist or what ratio.
So this is pretty much it, right?
So let me just show you one thing.
This is very important.
So notice this, okay?
This is, so let's assume that this is the 1M candle
and this is the 5M candle, all right?
Now, let's say that you mark out the low and the high
of the 1M candle.
But you see that the high and low were not taken out
in the next candle, which is the 5M candle.
So now we wanna stop looking at this candle
and we're gonna mark out the high
and low of the 5M candle.
Why?
Because the 5M candle could not,
couldn't take out the high and low of the 1M candle.
I repeat, if the high or the low of the 1M candle
1m candle is not taken out between the 5m candle,
then we wait for the 5m candle to close.
And then we mark out the 5m candle high and low.
And that's where our focus is going to go.
We forget about the 1m candle.
And then we look for the price of the 5m low
and we target the high.
So thank you so much for watching.
Please practice, all right?
Just by watching this and trading this on the live market, it's not going to help you.
Go and back test and see the results by yourself.